得意得って何なまず特の定義をしようよ
自然のものはみんな特なんだ人間が肉体と
精神に分かれとる肉体も得な精神の中で
自然のものあるもの本能だこれが得それを
育てようこれが得意じゃない何べも言っ
てるように正しいあるいは善これは本能の
ことだ理性は間違い簡単な例では自動車
事故やね自動車事故が起こるから自動車を
なくせて誰も言わ自動車はハード運転の
仕方がソフト自動車事故という悪いことは
ソフトで起こるんだ人間に言ってみよう
人間の精神本能がハード理性はソフトなん
本能の使い方だから悪い悪これは理性の中
にあるんだ本能は善なんだから本能は全だ
から人間はここまで生き延びたんだよ理性
のない時からずっとま永遠と人間は種族
保存を続けて今我々がおるんじゃないだっ
たら本のが正し真それを曲げちまうのが
理性やろ本能通りの行動すれのに本能を
曲げた行動するじゃんこれが悪なんだから
得意というのは正しいもの本能をしっかり
させよう精神のうちでね精神が大事だから
人間はこれが得意本能のトレーニングを
すれば
いい本能をどうやってトレーニングするか
知ってる聞いたことないです知っとるわけ
ないじゃんやってもらってないもんそう
いうことよねこれがうちのやってたことな
んだ本能のトレーニングだから正しくなる
本能が正しいんだから完璧な本能を作れば
これは正しい正しいことができる本のが
間違ってたりダメだったり弱かったりする
と大にして間違った行動をさせる悪い行動
をする気候なんか見とったらそうやね長
本道弱いもんね文部化学書は今どういう
得意をされてです文部学書なんてそんな風
に思ってないもんリベラル使っとるんだ
から精神論が間違っとるのに日本みたいに
本能と理性に分けるなんてことができない
当然本のトレーニングしない何しろ
ラショナル欧米の精神論では本は悪なんだ
理性が善な逆転しとるよね性前説という
あの性というのは本能のことだ本能が善
ですよというのが生前説欧米の精神論は
本能が悪だと言ってんだからあれは性悪説
その代わり理性が善と言って逆転さしとる
んよねだからヤは本当に悪いことするやろ
欧米人というのは世界制服しやがってそこ
の国の大物財をみんな略奪していってそれ
がないと人間を略奪してきて奴隷にして
あれほど悪いことをした連中なんであんな
悪いことができたの理性が全というそれが
あったからそれにちょっと宗教も絡んどる
んやけね前説と制約説は生前説の方が絶対
的に正しいんですか正しいに決まっとる
じゃんもし生が悪だったら我々は存在し
ないもう滅びるよ我々が今ここに存すると
いうのは生前説だからそれで存在しとる生
前説なんだからで本のこれを正しく強く
トレーニングしようよ元々正しいんだから
強くすればええんだそれには方法がある
うちはそれをやっとるこれはね受では公然
の木という公然の木ありがたいことに公然
の木の養い方つまり本能のトレーニングの
仕方具体的に書いてあるんだよさらに残念
なことには学者のその部分の役は間違っ
とるんだ受業学者ともあろうものが当然の
気は理解できんだよねこれは申しやねこの
中に高村中辺っていうとこがあるそこの心
動かさざる不同心一般的には申しの不同心
という風に呼ばれとる部分があってそれを
きっちりきっちりだよいい加減に読んだっ
てだめきっちり読むと本能のトレーニング
の仕方が書いてあるんだうちがやってる
ことはさらに素晴らしいことやってるここ
に書いてある以上のだからしっかりな特が
善なんだから善精神の善やね徳育をすると
善なる人間が出来上がるもう1つ言うとね
強いというのは正しい強いと正しいは一致
するんだついでに優しいこれも一致するん
だ強いと優しいはねだから女の子は自分の
天使を選ぶ時に優しい人っていうあれは
強いを意味しとるんだよね強い人は全だ
から自分の停止としてはいいじゃない
コメント欄であったんですけど格闘家とか
で普段のそこが悪い人とかは強いけど
正しくないんじゃないかっていう反論が
ありましたそうだよだけど肉体的に強いん
であったら精神的に強いわけはないやろ
優しいもあるもみんなそうだ精神が強い小
学校の時とか道徳って科目があったんです
けどあれは徳育ではないんですかはいあれ
徳育やけど喋ってできるかここに書いて
あるよ申しの中にともかく義義の意味が
分かるかなリリト人情なんていうもんで義
が悪いことやと思っとる人が多いけど義と
いうのは正しい行動これを義と言うんだ義
を行いて生ずるものにして遅いてこれを
取るものにあざるなり行動で正しい行動を
してると本のが強くなるだけど遅いてこれ
を取る勉強して人がこれは義だよと言った
もの一緒にあこれが義家と理解したって
ほの強くならないよ道徳は先生から教わっ
てるんでよくそうそうあんなもの
トレーニングにならないねだから偏差中さ
だめやろ悪いことばっかりするじゃん力を
悪用するよね育で具体的に本能を
トレーニングする方法ってどういうのが
あるんですかそれがないから問題ないん
やろうちはそれができるだから本当の教育
ができるんやね教えてやら
ない校長の認める食育やってるところて
何か他にあったりしますか厳しいとこは
割と得意やっとるよね右翼でけしからんと
いうマスコミが言うようなとこ得意やっ
とるよね視聴者に得意を行うヒントみたい
なものをいただけないでしょうかこれはね
うちが苦労して作り上げた方法だただで
教えてもらうと思うな誰が教えてやるかだ
けど来たら実際にやってやるよ大人はもう
手遅れなんですか本能が完成すんのはいつ
ぐらいやろねおそらく小学校の定学年
ぐらいでおしまいやないかなその間が今
甘い世界にしてるやろいじめはいかんの
しってはいかんのあれで本能ができないや
ね大人になってから得意するためには何か
方法ってありますかソフトで補うより
しょうがないじゃん今まで作り上げてきた
本能を正しく出すソフトそれを作ったら本
の育にはならんけど育間のことはできるわ
なそれが昔やってた徳育じゃない道徳教ね
私の言うことは正しいことばっかりだだ
から今からまだ続くから正しい人生死ぬ時
に満足の行く人生それを送りたければ
チャンネル登録してずっと聞いてくれ